So today I will talk about how we're going to optimize the alloconditioning regimen for patients, for older patients with AML and MDS using the triosulfam glues conditioning.
So this is my disclosure for this talk.
Oops, that looks a little bit different, but obviously the transplant for older patients continue to increase, you know.
So now we are treating patients with more comorbidities and with less biologic reserve.
They have higher risk or even higher risk disease that require a curative therapy.
So reduced intensity conditioning regimen definitely could help us to expand the transplant access to those patients by reducing the treatment-related mortality.
But again, relapse risk is the cost that we have to pay.
When we think about transplant conditioning regimen, we're typically thinking about as a spectrum.
So the transplant conditioning intensity score helps to...
Quantify to put the given regimen along the spectrum.
And what it's showing here consistently, as you can see that when we increase the intensity, the treatment-related mortality also increase.
And for older patients, it is amplified.
So this effect is amplified with age.
So for older patients, when we increase the intensity, it's not linear.
It's really biological amplified.
So there's really obvious needs to have a better balance between the toxicity and the antiloquemic effect.
For this particular patient population.
So triosulfan-based conditioning regimen could be an approach that helps us to achieve that balance.
So this is a prodrug alkylator with some favorable characteristics.
Like, you know, predictable PK, non-enzymatic activation, consistent DNA cross-linking.
So it could help to provide a reliable myeloablation.
On the other hand, that it seems like...
The toxicity profile could be better compared to the bosulfan-based approach.
So this is one of the earliest experience with triosulfan-based conditioning at the U.S.
So at FEDHUCH, we evaluated patients in a prospective study using triosulfan fludarabine with or without low-dose TBI.
This is a high-risk patient population, including AML, MDS, CMML, and many of those patients had the features that would...
Have very high risk of relapse.
So what we're seeing here vary consistently across all patients on both groups that we can achieve.
Very stable engraftment with no patient have graft rejection and also very stable journal chimerism on day 28 and 84.
So that confirmed that the triosulfan-based conditioning could provide a very reliable conditioning platform.
So when we look...
At other outcomes for patients who receive additional low-dose of TBI, they have less risk of relapse.
But very interestingly, that the non-relapse mortality, despite the fact with additional low-dose of TBI, it's remained really low at 9%.
And this is very important, telling us that, yes, we can improve the control, the disease control when maintaining the low toxicity.
So this...
This is the outcomes.
This is just, you know, to show you that the outcomes actually more pronounced for patient with AML and for patient with high risk of relapse, particularly for patient with unfavorable cytogenetics.
So we're moving from the very encouraging single center data set to the next step.
This is a phase three randomized trial that comparing the trioflurabine conditioning versus...
the busulfan and fludarabine conditioning for older patient with AML/NDS.
And I think that probably, you know, this is the most important randomized data set that we have in this space.
So in this trial, about 500 patients involved in this trial randomized one-to-one to either arms, so the age up to 70.
And those patients, they required to have high comorbidity burden or other features that make them not the ideal candidate for the conventional MAC transplant approach.
So looking at the EFS, we started seeing, you know, the signal favoring the triosulfan-based conditioning.
So the curve separated quite early and then maintained separated over time.
And very importantly, so that advantage translated to the overall survival as well, which make it much more clinically meaningful.
So we look closer to see what is driving this and we can see that, you know, for the relapse rate is similar between the two.
two groups when the non-relapse mortality is significantly lower for the triosulfan-based arm.
So this is telling us that, you know, this is exactly what we're looking for for the older
patient population approach, like we can maintain the antiloquemic effect when reducing the toxicity
of the conditioning regimen that led to the advantage of overall survival. So, you know,
from outside of the prospective trial, this EBMT analysis is very important because
it evaluates a very challenging situation where they're comparing the outcomes of
fludarabine N3014, CRAM, versus flubufor in patients with active AML, meaning primary
refractory or relapse disease at the time of transplant. So this is kind of the stress test
of the condition.
So we can see here very encouraging data as well that, you know, the patient who received the
triosulfan-based, they have less relapse risk. That led to the advantage of disease-free or
leukemic-free survival and overall survival. And then the non-relapse mortality, including
acute and chronic GVHD, similar between the two.
This is just another clinical trial to registry data, including more than 1,200 patients, again,
older AML/MDS patient comparing flutrio versus flumel of SIBU. Again, I'm not going to go through
all the numbers here, but a couple of key points that are important for us to be aware that, you
know, those patients who received the flutrio conditioning regimen have higher comorbidity
abundance, that's reflecting with higher SCTCI score, age, and then, you know, performance status
and disease risk seems to be very familiar across all the group. So for the AML patients, relapse
risk are similar among the groups, but the non-relapse mortality obviously significantly
lower for the patient who received the triobase conditioning. And again, that led to the
advantage of improving overall survival for patients with MDS.
As you know, all the outcomes seem to be similar among the groups. So taking all together,
I think that from the retrospective, from the prospective data to the registry data
or slash reward data, I can see that, you know, the message is pretty consistent, that
how to improve the therapeutic index in transplant, particularly for these patient population,
older patient population, not only, you know, escalating the intensity, but more importantly,
we have to optimize the toxicity of the conditioning. So, and of course, we taking it to the transplant
to the HAPLO platform. This is the ongoing trial that we have at the Hodge. And that
with that, I close my talk and thank you for your attention.